друзі Сьогодні 23 лютого і в Росії
будуть розповідати про день защитника
отечества и будет розповідати щось своїм
солдатам Що Ідіть воюйте давайте несіть
русские мир Я хочу звернутися до
російських солдат вас тут нічого не
чекає вас не чекають тут німецьці
Краматорська Маріуполя Харкова Одеси
Києва з квітами в руках Ми вас чекаємо з
джевелінами і зі зброєю в руках якщо ви
сюди зайдете ви звідси вже ніколи не
вийдете це ми вам обіцяємо Добро
пожаловать в ад це ми Вам можемо сказати
і ви тут помрете помрете як фальшиві пси
якщо ви зайдете в нашу державу і ваші
генерали які кидають вас в цю м'ясорубку
вони будуть ватям перші тікати Тому
зараз кидайте зброю ідіть додому до
своїх дітей до своїх жінок тут вам нема
чого робити це не ваша земля і ніколи
людей не буде ми обов'язково переможемо
щоби і ніхто вам не розповідав і він
перемога Буде за нами Україна буде
вільною А ви залишитесь тут на вічно в
цій землі оце ваше майбутнє